es ist längst kein protest mehr was sich
in ottawa seit fast drei wochen abspielt
es ist die belagerung der hauptstadt
einer der bislang stabilsten demokratien
der welt seit ende januar blockieren
gewaltige maschinen parlament und
regierung sitzt und ein ende ist nicht
in sicht wir sind in otter war unterwegs
wollen verstehen was die umtreibt die
gekommen sind was das alles bedeutet
weit über kanada hinaus und wie es so
weit kommen konnte viele hier wollen den
im vergangenen jahr erst wieder
gewählten premierminister justin trio
und seine regierung loswerden sie fühlen
sich von der regierung und ihren anti
cupid regel gegängelt
schafft alle diese gesetzlosen mandate
abschafft die masken pflicht ab und
lasst mich in ruhe da werde ich nicht
nachgeben
ich wurde in kanada geboren ich war
immer frei in kanada keiner kann mir
etwas anderes erzählt
niemand nicht der premierminister nicht
der papst jesus kann zu mir sprechen und
jesus sagt mir du hast recht
entzündet hatte sich alles an der
impfpflicht für lkw fahrer die die
kanadisch amerikanischen grenze
passieren 90 prozent der mehr als
200.000 kanadischen trucker sind
vollständig geben ihre gewerkschaften
unterstützen die belagerung awtowas
nicht die aber die sich nicht impfen
lassen wollen sehen sich durch die
regierung ihrer freiheit beraubt und so
mancher vermutet hinter der impfpflicht
sogar eine verschwörung
wir haben keine kontrolle über unsere
körper mehr alles wird von der regierung
bestimmt die meiner meinung nach
iranischer
erinnern sie sich nicht mehr daran dass
sie mit den juden gemacht haben bin ich
jetzt ein jude bin ich ein hund in die
hunde spritzen sie mikrochips und das
wollen sie jetzt mit uns machen
am wochenende wird die straße vor dem
parlament zur partymeile halligalli wie
am ballermann
bei fast minus 30 grad sie unterstützen
die belagerung die ihm hoffnung sie sagt
es waren zwei dunkle jahre für mich
persönlich mit psychischen problemen die
kinder nicht in der schule und alle hat
das betroffen unser leben hat sich auf
den kopf gestellt dass ihr bedeutet mir
viel die stimmung ist super hier wir
hatten das schon seit zwei jahren nicht
mehr
es geht darum unser leben
zurückzubekommen und wieder frei zu sein
so wie es vor zwei jahren war
doch ganz so harmlos wie es auf den
ersten blick daher kommt ist alles nicht
was ich hier in ottawa seit drei wochen
abspiele habe nichts mehr mit einem
einfachen protest gegen den von masken
pflicht zu tun sondern sehr viel mehr
und es recht sei es kein spontaner
aufstand von aufgebrachten kanadischen
lkw fahrer zieht uns briner anderson von
der universität
es ist auch eine besatzung hat elemente
einer blockade
manche bezeichnen es als geiselnahme und
erpressung
es ist eine konzertierte aktion um das
leben der bewohner in der stadt so stark
zu stören dass es unausstehlich wird um
damit die regierung an den
verhandlungstisch zu bringen
dann gibt es elemente ausländischer
einmischung
politische unterstützung aus den usa
finanzierung und fundraising
die belagerer sind quasi militärisch
organisiert
stützpunkten rund um die hauptstadt von
hier aus koordiniert die führung der
bewegung darunter bekannte kanadische
rechtsextreme die nächsten schritte wir
sind hier nicht wirklich willkommen
können nur heimlich mit dem handy einen
kurzen weg ins innere werfen die
versorgung der fahrer vor ort mit benzin
und lebensmitteln ist eine große
logistische operation auf die man hier
sehr stolz ist die fahrer selbst werden
damit völlig überfordert
da sei eine große herausforderung
unterstützung in fragen
irgendwie schauen ja die haben wir
mehr aber will er uns dazu nicht sagen
fest steht jetzt 50 prozent der
unterstützer die gelder die sogenannte
frieden konvoi bewegung spenden kommen
aus dem ausland das ist mittlerweile
belegt die meisten aus den usa viele
fundamentalistische christen und
anhänger der in jahrzehnten ist
professor für nationale sicherheit hat
32 jahre für den kanadischen
geheimdienst gearbeitet und er hat eine
erklärung warum soviel amerikanisches
geld die kanadische bewegung ist die ing
ihr ziel ist es nicht kanadiern zu
helfen sie machen sich nichts los
kanadier ihr ziel ist es die illusion
einer basisbewegung zu schaffen die zu
ihren politischen zielen in den staaten
passt schaut's aus die kanadier machen
das sind helden wir müssen hier in den
staaten auch so etwas machen sie wollen
nicht dass dieser aufstand in kanada
endet denn sie wollen eine solche
bewegung auch darum geht es ihnen sie
glauben dass ihnen die wahl gestohlen
wurde
die meisten kanadier fast 75 prozent
sind die belagerung ihrer hauptstadt
leiht den otter war selbst holen die
anwohner zum gegenschlag aus blockieren
ihrerseits konvois die in die stadt
fahren
das ist eine gegendemonstration zu der
in downtown wir wollen unsere stadt
wieder haben wir wollen dass sie nach
hause gehen
mir geht auch viele fans werk mein leben
ist auch voller unannehmlichkeiten und
ich nehme an dass auch geht hier allen
so
aber wir würden doch nicht im traum
daran denken einen solchen staatsstreich
in zeitlupe mitzumachen wie den in den
usa am sechsten januar
die gleichen leute die den sechsten
januar orchestriert haben die trappisten
die rechten konservativen in den usa
sind die gleichen die das hier von außen
unterstützen
ein schnelles ende der belagerung
ottawas ist nicht in sicht und die
polizei der hauptstadt scheint völlig
überfordert lässt die belagerer seit
fast drei wochen gewähren kann er das
regierung rennt die zeit davon jeden tag
den die krise andauert wird sie schwäche
mit der aktivierung des
notstandsgesetzes wie sie die belagerung
jetzt beenden so wie es die mehrheit der
bürgerinnen von ihr erwartet aber das
risiko dass die sache völlig aus dem
ruder läuft ist groß